we turn now to central africa where
devastating volcanic eruption has killed
at least 15 people lava flowed into
villages in the eastern part of the
democratic republic of congo formerly
known as zaire
thousands of frantic people fled to
safety across the border into rwanda
unicef says more than 170 children are
feared
missing as deborah patter reports a
major city was spared from the
destruction
but other parts of the country were not
so lucky
as the nighttime sky turned a fiery red
panic spread across gomer
i remember we saw the same signs before
said resident john kelosho
we don't know what to do there is no
information
just six miles away mount nelogongo had
erupted again
spewing rivers of hot lava that snaked
their way
towards the lakeside city home to at
least
two million people those who remember
the last eruption of 2002
were terrified the deadly tragedies
would be repeated
that disaster left 250 people
dead and 120 000 homeless
in the absence of official communication
nobody waited around to see what would
happen this time
and so they fled heading for higher
ground
or the nearby rwandan border
the insistent ring of cell phones
piercing the air
as frantic families checked in on loved
ones
by morning the devastation was clear
homes had been engulfed by flames
entire villages raised to the ground
i cursed this day sobbed 68 year old
ernestine kabour
as she stumbled through the smoldering
rubble
her husband had been burnt to death in
their home
he was too sick to run she
too frail to carry him
aid workers are still assessing the
damage it could take
months to rebuild shattered communities
for now panic has given way to molded
curiosity
as people who escaped the worst of it
took selfies amidst the still-glowing
molten ash
the last eruption saw the lava flow
through the city for over a day
but this time gomer was spared
i've been to gomer several times and
have a pretty good idea of where that
lava was actually headed
and i can tell you that it's nothing
short of remarkable that it stopped
just before the city limits the
immediate danger has receded but
residents tell us
that they are still experiencing
frightening tremors gail
it is very frightening what a contrast
between where you are now and what you
just showed us thank you very much
deborah powder reporting from south
africa